we have the brand spanking new iPhone 15
Pro Max and boy is it refreshing and a
little surreal to see apple finally
jumping on the USBC train with the 15
series of phones we'll be running this
Mammoth of a phone through our gaming
Gauntlet of honkai stereo Genji impact
pubg mobile and there's a little treat
we'll be kicking things off by trying
out Resident Evil village with a PS5
controller on the iPhone 15 Pro Max to
see what the hype is all about Resident
Evil Village is a console game mind you
so how well does it play on the
smartphone let's find out if it's as
amazing as it sounds and how about the
phone can handle all these amazing games
of course new iPhones means fresh ticks
on their Hardware performance wise the
iPhone 15 Pro Max is running the a17 pro
chip and one terabyte of storage the
display is a 6.7 inch super retina xdr
OLED screen running at 120 hertz before
we run the test let's do a baseline of
the temperatures of the front and back
of the phone with our trusty temperature
gun all right I'm gonna lay this out
flat so you guys can see everything all
right so from top 25 29
this has been my hand for a bit so 29.6
29.7 not too bad
nothing too drastic I mean we just
started right
okay and the front 29 29.5
28.6 yep pretty much the same as the
back except the bottom half is you know
kind of coursing towards the 30 degrees
Celsius Mark but other than that it's
fine
so first things first you actually have
a UI down here to you know play without
a controller but I wouldn't recommend
that all right so now with the main menu
let's check settings
and display and yeah we can't do
anything about it we can change anything
running at 30 FPS and pretty much
everything else is set for us
I can't even change the brightness
yeah okay so I can't change the
brightness or anything
so you guys are going to make do this
game takes up half of the 8 gigs of RAM
that we have on the phone so yeah with
that let's just head straight into
Resident Evil Village cuttings are
playing are very smoothly right now so
with that let's just skip this and get
straight into the playable sections of
the game all right skip that I'm sorry
but you know we got things to do we
gotta keep moving
oh look at that it's cute what the hell
First Impressions honestly if
man this feels like it's like I'm
playing on the switch but if I could do
this I man I wouldn't need to switch at
all we are moving cool
very cool I believe we have to go
upstairs right
okay I can't spray oh shut oh
oh
where is my wife there you go
that smells good what's that oh hands
off Mister all right skip this
skip
oh oh yes okay so you're here now skip
so far no fairy drops nothing this thing
is handling this game like a champ I
know it's a bit dark at the start but
I'm hoping it gets bright though very
nice details
oh God okay
and now uh jump down I'm not even trying
to like be super excited about it this
thing is actually it's crazy oh this is
working out on an iPhone it's one thing
to have extreme games but it's another
thing to have a whole game a whole
console game on a phone working out 10
minutes into the game we are currently
at
you're still 100 wow okay I would expect
it to like drop by now but we're still
100 that's
that's insane okay 10 minutes in on a
full-fledged console game on an iPhone
and we're still 100
that is crazy what the hell okay whoa 3
9 32 what it
apparently the king barely made it in
this thing is the game is properly
optimized for the iPhone Let's either
beat the Early Access whatever it's this
thing is wow okay that's a pretty good
build
all right
Good Hits what happened
oh yes I remember this fight
guy almost takes her head off
who sent you nobody it was an accident
down the road
what's going on
I don't think that's good
oh oh
[Applause]
oh I see it now
oh man
nope ah damn it
stand back
we actually do need to find a way out of
here
oh
oh yeah what happens now
okay uh I believe when you shoot a guy
no no no no no no no no no no okay
that's just peachy
I only have four rounds right now my guy
but we have created a
okay I only have one
and I used to go Crystal Skull 20
minutes in ish 30 minutes in so with
that let's do oh
that's not good
they're only somewhere
oh
okay so uh with that let us check
temperatures and rest of the evil
Village plays pretty well on the iPhone
15 Pro Max so let's check Final
temperatures for this game before we get
into the engine impact and the rest
so 38 all right you know what that's
fair 39 in the middle
35 ish
all right we're doing pretty good here
let's check the back
all right honestly again let's handheld
this a little bit not wow okay it
doesn't feel that hard honestly let's
check the back here real quick ah 36.835
34 36
damn 39.6
yeah this thing handles heat like a
champ all right let's check batteries
real quick we got 96 guys about close to
half an hour of playing Resident Evil or
at least 20 minutes and we are only down
five well now five percent that's insane
93 right now we ended off at 95 in the
previous game 34-35 we just ended the
game so a little bit of residual here
and there 35.2 but honestly it has been
dissipated hit pretty well okay so from
the bottom 34.1
all right 34.7 35.3 yeah this thing
really does handle heat like a champ all
right 38.1 at the top here 37.8 nothing
too drastic I mean obviously we just
ended the game so you know
it is what it is all right and with that
let's get into our settings so settings
wise we are on very high for everything
60 FPS everything is on the highest
right now yeah and honestly March looks
really good switch out to Japan
and look at his fur coat here look at
the Shadows I mean just like Resident
Evil this thing looks great so swipe
no frame rate drops whatsoever this
looks really good and another sample all
right so you want to drill
simulated Universe let's go he's sick
and just whack
we're just having fun sounds pretty good
honestly the speaker's great and let's
just bounce
yeah that's hella smooth
IE all right
I should have went for the middle one
but never mind it is Aoki
okay that's it first battle everything's
worked out very smooth no friendly drops
nothing this phone man
all right bounce
okay let's go for an ulti real quick all
right and see how well it plays out
honestly I'm expecting the best
[Music]
look at that that's great all right
let's go with much salty
let's go all right let's whack
there we go nice we should be able to
break this concentration but also let's
see if your parts I'll be
it's quite intensive
and okay yeah a little bit of a steering
job right there just a little bit
oh okay yeah you saw that okay just a
little bit nothing too concerning but
primary jobs on the list
it should be fine
oh okay yeah we're more than fine okay
sick seven minutes ish into this play
through and let's just check settings
real quick currently we are at 90 they
took out five percent battery wow okay
that's a huge contrast compared to
Resident Evil Village let's check the
front
41 yeah okay that definitely feels like
41. 43 here 40 foot wow okay 38.1 yeah
14 40.9 46 wow what what 46 where
damn okay 48 40.8 38 and 39 honestly it
doesn't feel like these numbers but you
know it is kind of getting a little bit
toasty right now at 44. okay okay so
we're gonna be visiting the final boss
of this will be similar to the universe
and okay I have to say that we are
playing this a couple days before the
release and honestly honkai stereo
compared to see Resident Evil Resident
Evil has had a lot more time to you know
be more polished up and everything as a
port so to be fair I wonder how this
performs like after Hong Kong stereo is
optimized for the iPhone 15 Pro Max and
just the iPhone 15 Series in general I
think it will turn out pretty well so
just keep that in mind especially when
we play the other games because
obviously at the time recording this
phone isn't even out yet for the rest of
y'all so just take note of that all
right
all right stack everything up
shall never fall
very nice a lot smoother now
it's nice got a break oh we're actually
taking him out first that's the first
you know series here
all right oh
okay never mind
let's go
okay that's one down
last one to go
[Music]
nice all right temperature gun
all right 35
36.2 we're gonna be going out the middle
here 37 40 39.2 41 44 43.9 okay so there
has been a little bit of a drop let's
check the front I need the bag let's
check the back real quick
from Top
42.7 45 42 4p 0.1 and yeah that's pretty
much constant as we get lower it it does
get lower yeah
and as we go lower here you know the
number does get lower so yeah it's to be
expected so with that I'll take it last
note again it's not optimized just yet
for the iPhone 15 Pro Max so just keep
that in mind and probably for the rest
of the games that we're going to be
playing as well before we get into the
next game this channel is bought by
Brands who help us improve our content
and keep us going so stay around for the
sponsored message meet the Cyber 15
gaming laptop from MSI check out this
translucent material design that not
only looks good but feels good thanks to
its Ultra lightweight chassis at only
1.98 kilograms give yourself the upper
Edge in gaming with its blazing fast
performance powered by the latest 12 gen
Intel Core i7 hch processor and Nvidia
RTX 4000 series gpus and stay immersed
with its the heavy twin speaker sound
system that provides an auditory Feast
like no other for more details check out
msi.com so we are heart of the heels of
honkai style of course we are going to
be playing getting impact next we are
currently 82 we've got by one percent in
the moment that we've stopped honkai
star rail so let's just check
temperatures real quick again it's quite
warm but we shall see how well this
thing dissipates heat or if it stays at
a constant rate for Genji impact
so we are 39 the top here 40. all right
still really isn't going down just yet
it's still about 40 years in the front
still pretty warm all right 40.7
41.640 38.73.4 3.7 all right so things
are cooling down just not as fast as I
think just not as fast as I thought it
would cool down but
in hand it's still comfortable to hold
it's kind of like a nice snuggly kind of
form it's not like it's going to burn my
hand itself kind of warm but yeah I
think this should do so with that let's
get into Genji impact
all right so with that let's get into
the engine impact
all right we're back in Inazuma City and
boy this is beautiful look at the
Sunrise goddamn that is beautiful
alright so Graphics wise we are set to
high highs on everything 60 FPS
everything is turned on the highest so
that let's run through
it's really good
travel look at her
she's looking beautiful to get the
little Sakura petals falling down and
let's change the dialogue real quick and
look at that
all of the details are on screen right
now it's it's beautiful photography
all right now all right it's looking
pretty good let's look at that look and
let's start running around the city
all right so far pretty smooth
a little bit of feeling drops in there
just a little bit
all right let's keep running
[Music]
and yeah so far so good I believe I mean
things are still rendering in right now
other than that I think it's doing okay
considering the fact that you know we
still are pretty much playing this
before the game gets optimized for this
brand new iPhone
and the series so just give it a little
bit up
so just be uh yeah so cut it some slack
you know
I think that's looking pretty good I
think that's looking really good right
now right and let's keep moving
and I think with that
things are looking pretty good so far I
mean things are still running in as we
walk past them
so let's go do some exploration and
probably some callback all right so we
are out here and yep
it's not properly optimized yet so just
keep that in mind
um that it's uh pretty smooth
it's looking pretty good but yeah very
drastic favorite drops man okay I mean
it is going to impact the soul there's
always going to be some kind of boating
issue or optimization issue but let's
keep
cut the full cut the points of slack you
know this thing is I'm still playing the
thing before it's even released so it's
got some slack and let's get in here
no combat very fluid so far
no major feeling jobs but then let's uh
burn this whole place down
oh
yeah okay
I would have to say that this game looks
beautiful and yeah we are fighting right
now
running this is pretty good
we gotta keep running
that's not good all right so uh reading
this is pretty good as you can see the
monsters on the sides and a huge tree
over there so no complaints here about
that all right
oh
all right it should be easy work
honestly
there we go let's just keep hitting them
and there we go box your uncle so with
the previous fight with a much larger
enemy you know there wasn't any huge
fearing jobs or any drastic fairing jobs
which is the funny thing compared to us
fighting all the small guys
they're all mushroom dudes which is
crazy so uh with that let's just go to
the spiral bit to see what's up
okay so to be honest okay so just to be
honest you know playing on this so far
has been pretty fun it's just that I
just wish it was optimized but that's a
matter of timing and whatnot so
besides that this thing plays pretty
well it's very smooth
[Music]
yeah bend it out
all right let's keep going
okay
all right the opinion dropped something
everything's playing very smoothly right
now
feet of light
all right
remember dudes
very nice
oh yeah I still can't pronounce his name
but yeah she's doing pretty well for us
all right and that's the last one okay
so it's been a bit of a journey with
Genji impact but let's check Final
temperatures all right we are currently
at 75 so
let's just check temperatures
40.6 40.2 3.7
3.2 all right let's check the back all
right let's check the back all right
let's check temperatures to the back
real quick
all right
34.2 35 right things have calmed down
quite a bit you know things have really
cooled down the back can't see it so
much at the front it's kind of keeping
it similar to okay stereo but that's
kind of again to be expected
so with that let's get into
the final game pubg mobile
all right so we are heart of the heels
of Genji impact currently we are at 74
so let's check temperatures before we
start pubg mobile which of course will
be played on the smooth settings because
everyone wants to see FPS performance
and here we go 3637 right things have
calmed down quite a bit things have
really gone down quite a lot in front
let's check the back
all right back temperatures right now 37
37 36 38.9 35 36 all right we are in the
green right now okay so this thing again
kind of handles heat pretty well
but obviously that's depending on the
strain of the game so yeah you know it
is what it is all right so let's go pubg
mobile all right so let's go pubg mobile
let's check our settings real quick
all right graphics and audio we are
smooth for graphics right now extreme
frame rate phone times in interior
listing four times in the aliasing and
yeah we're good for a match so let's go
all right so your property mobile you
guys want to see frame rates so that's
what we're doing frame rates honestly
other than that the game looks great and
I'm okay with this
all right let's see how well it handles
all right let's jump
right so far pretty smooth no Ferry
drops and everything I mean honestly
again we're not playing the most
demanding Graphics so this thing can
handle pubg mobile pretty well
all right let's get down
still a ways to go honestly
all right pretty close
get high and now as we descend
yes
and just hit straight down
and obviously our guys are going to the
other side so no one's with me okay I
can survive this I've done a survivorous
so this is fine
this is okay
no one else in range so far so good
what was the SLR inside here oh yes it
was okay
so about
sorry
gonna have to drag you out
this guys did
foreign
oh okay it's a lot easier than I
expected
I'll take it
I'll take that as well
oh there you are
oh
this one down that's what we're gonna do
it on the horizon over there
you go
oh for a headshot
all right that's one way to end the
match woohoo
okay sick with that
let us check our final temperatures and
get into our conclusion and all that
all right 36.1 37.5
okay things have gone down quite a bit
25.734.4 and
yeah okay the back is doing pretty good
it's actually really good at dissipating
Heat at the back honestly all right and
at the end we are at 66 percent and
honestly that's about after an hour and
a half ish a fast playing four different
games so with that let's get into our
final thoughts the iPhone 15 Pro Max is
just impressive not only because Apple
ensures that a port for a game that
Resident Evil Village would play so
smoothly especially how well it works
with the PS5 controller and
transitioning from playing with the
on-screen controls and back to the
controller for something on test flight
just proves further how much they care
about the details hunger style and Genji
impact unfortunately hasn't been fully
optimized for the 15 series as of yet
again we are shooting this video way
ahead of launch so with that in mind I
can't wait to actually play these
Horrible's games again because we will
all be in for a glorious time once
that's done pubg played extremely smooth
unsurprisingly and the size of the phone
is perfect for laying out controls and
catching opponents off guard with smooth
button inputs and swipes without any
issue shoes would you be getting the
iPhone 15 Pro Max or any of the others
from the iPhone 15 lineup let me know in
the comment section below leave your
questions there and we'll do our best to
get to them if you like what we do make
sure to follow us all our socials right
here and maybe leave a like and hit that
subscribe button it costs a long way if
you want to see more stuff check this
out